auf der sonnen aufnahme der us
weltraumbehörde nasa ist eine schwarze
fläche zu erkennen die sich nach unten
hin ausbreiten in wirklichkeit aber
steckt ein gigantisches loch in der
oberen atmosphäre dahinter und es
schießt einen partikel strahl in
richtung unserer erde dieses kommunale
loch ist nicht nur mega spannend sondern
auch ziemlich beunruhigen denn es
entstehen immer mehr dieser löcher und
sie bedrohen die erde was genau steckt
dahinter und wie gefährlich können sie
uns wirklich werden die antworten jetzt
bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle facts zu den sogenannten koronalen
löchern die für uns hier auf der erde
eine erhebliche gefahr darstellen wenn
er übrigens auch auf dabei sein wollt
und vor allen anderen meine videos sehen
wollt dann bleibt bis zum ende des
videos dran da gibt es die
entsprechenden infos also so konkret
geht es um so genannte koronare löcher
auch wenn sie ziemlich dunkel aussehen
sie sind es eigentlich nicht denn diese
löcher erscheinen so dunkel weil ihre
fläche kühler und weniger dicht ist als
die der restlichen sonne und kommunale
löcher sind gar nicht so selten es
handelt sich also um stellen mit einer
niedrigen dichte im magnetfeld hier
entweicht plasma also die sonnenwinde
mit höchstgeschwindigkeiten und zwar
deutlich schneller als normal ins all
sie werden zu wahren sonnensturm in
einer mitteilung des space weather
prediction center das heißt es eine
offene magnetfeldlinien struktur sorgt
dafür dass sonnenwinde leichter ins all
gelangen können was zu strömen von sehr
schnellen winden führt demnach können
sich forscher immer und überall auf der
sonne entwickeln doch besonders
verbreitet und stabil sind sie am
solaren nord und südpol sie sind
langlebiger als sonnenflecken und
überleben oft einige monate ein
beeindruckendes kommunales loch hat die
nasa im juli vergangenen jahres entdeckt
es sendete partikel ströme richtung erde
und diese sonnenwinde beziehungsweise
das waren schon sonnenstürme erschienen
dann als kräftige polarlichter am himmel
im süden der usa
denn wenn die elektrisch also im süden
der usa
denn wenn die elektrisch geladenen
teilchen des sonnenwindes in die nähe
der erde kommen werden sie vom
erdmagnetfeld abgelenkt zu den polen
sobald sie mit luftteilchen
zusammenstoßen ionisieren sie in einer
höhe von bis zu vier kilometern prallen
sie auf die atome der lufthülle und umso
stärker sie sind umso weiter im süden
kann man sie sehen die so betroffenen
teilchen werden dabei eben zum leuchten
angeregt ein echt tolles naturschauspiel
doch krone löcher sind auch gefährlich
für die zivilisation und sie werden
immer mehr und damit steigt die gefahr
forschungsteams weltweit gehen davon aus
dass es nämlich in der nächsten zeit
weniger sonnenflecken und sonnen
geben wird dann aber nehmen die
kommunalen löcher zu und beschleunigen
die weniger wenigen sonnenwinde zu eben
den gefürchteten sonnenstürmen und die
sind dann gefährlich beziehungsweise
noch gefährlicher forschungsteams wollen
deswegen unbedingt mehr über diese
gigantischen löcher erfahren denn die
starken sonnenstürme stören die
ionosphäre massiv so dass sich
funkwellen beispielsweise nicht mehr
ausbreiten können vor allem kurz und
ultrakurz wellen sind betroffen dort
findet vor allem der amateur und
mobilfunk stadt die kommunikation wird
dort unterbrochen auch gps kann
betroffen seien dann fallen die
navigationssysteme aus oder werden
zumindest erheblich gestört generell
können satelliten dann gestört werden
und damit unser weltweites
kommunikationsnetz und zudem können
solche sonnenstürme das strom- und
telekommunikationsnetz erheblich
beeinflussen und zum erliegen bringen
und wir haben hier ja darüber berichtet
es kann zu einer absoluten katastrophe
werden ein vorgeschmack gab es 1989 in
kanada als sechs millionen menschen bei
minus 15 grad stunden lang ohne strom
und fernwärme ausharren mussten die
schäden für die wirtschaft und
infrastruktur können verheerend sein und
jetzt steigen wohl die chancen für eine
solche katastrophe wenn er als erstes
neues zu diesem thema und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video das ist garantiert ihr
könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von
pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen
oder fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit und dafür draufklicken
super sonnenstürme treffen
unausweichlich die erde
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran